vendredi soir il y avait un nouveau
numéro de koh lanta les scieries et on a
eu une grande émotion
pendant cet épisode parce que les
aventuriers on peut écouter un message
de leurs proches
une séquence qui a ému les
téléspectateurs c'est celle de bertrand
kamal le mercer malheureusement
candidate décédé il ya quelques semaines
d'un cancer du pancréas qui a fondu en
larmes après un message de son père et
il était très proche
et quand il était sur l'aventuré ça a
été un gros gros moments ça dans koh
lanta koh lanta c'est vraiment ça bouge
pas au niveau ça cartonne autour de 5
millions de téléspectateurs
on pensait qu'elle est peut-être avoir
un effet après le décès de bertrand que
canal compte que les gens allaient
peut-être plus à l'est sur le programme
et comme c'est déjà énorme mais c'est
déjà énorme
bien sûr c'est un peu touche touche avec
france 2 mais ça reste leader chaque
semaine ses leaders et c'était un carton
et moi j'ai une grosse pensée pour la
famille me bertrand cabale ses parents
que j'ai vu dans les voilà dans le
portrait de bertrand gamal qui n'ont
l'air d'une gentillesse et son papa
voilà c'est un sportif et nous voilà je
me suis fait de gros bisous we ll hasard
a fait que j'étais à dijon le week-end
dernier d'où est originaire bertrand
cavalerie et je peux vous dire que
l'émotion qu'avait denis brogniart et
alexia laroche-joubert la productrice du
jeu n'était pas fan parce que la sens
sans aucune publicité ils sont dus voir
à revoir la famille ce qui amène
cérémonie par ses intimes on en revers
trop kamel quelques temps après la
cérémonie d'enterrement et ils étaient
tous là autour de la famille donc
c'était bravo bravo russe est enfin venu
de regarder cet extrait
[Musique]
j'ai le plus loin possible dans cette
aventure je te souhaite la réussite
monfils
[Musique]
ça lui fait pour lui et pour ma mère
nous
c'est hélas étrangers kolontar moment
d'histoire et aiguisé d'ailleurs son
père disait que c'était son coach à ses
vrais et c'est d'une génération on a du
mal à dire je t'aime et là il a dit ça
devait être un art marocain lui dire un
très bon moment surtout et c'est le
soleil de l'histoire après voilà c'est
vrai qu' on adore cet aventurier de
résonance d'ailleurs avec les réseaux
sociaux parce que cette séquence a été
commentée re commenté sur commenter
parce qu'effectivement ça a touché au
coeur des gens qui se projetait en
voyant le père le fils ce coup de fil
presque de l'au-delà quoi ça sert
je pense que si les bras ont validé
justement que les oui bien sûr c'est
peut-être pour ça aussi le monde sont
également impatient de voir leur fils
c'est pour ça qu'elle est forte je pense
une bonne chose que vous moi bravo à
l'action bravo à tf1 aussi d'avoir volé
une voiture parce qu'elle fait ce que
pour les parents travaillent je pense
que quand l'aventuré va se terminer au
contraire pour eux ça va ça va ça va
vendredi soir on a envie de le voir mais
nous on a envie de me voir me shooter
thème bien que l'on tape sur que tu
regardes un rachat dont tata somba je
suis content alors tu vois parce que si
c'est une émission qu'on adore et ça
marche très très faible que longtemps
koh lanta mais ça sera vraiment j'aurais
des beurs et tout ça carrément il le
fait michou bas si je t'envoie des
salaires durant c'est à dire c'est plus
facile d'aller sur koh lanta manger des
vers que passé trois jours chez bernard
[Rires]